hello I'm Mouse I'm talking about
mapping imaginary cities which are
procedurally generated I'm gonna save
some time for questions at the end so
feel free to use the slide SLI do app
and if you have questions during the
talk so this is the first thing that I
saw when I got off the plane because I
pulled it up on my phone maybe you did
too this is st. Louis um pretty cool but
this is not st. Louis this is this is a
screenshot of Google Maps that's being
projected on a screen I know I'm blowing
your mind bear with me and this is a map
pretty cool and this map is informative
it tells me some things about st. Louis
that I didn't know like there's a place
called Venice in Brooklyn and Dutch town
and that's cool and it's useful it
really helped me figure out how to get
from the hotel to or from the airport to
my hotel but this map is not complete no
matter how long I look at this map I'm
still not gonna know that much about st.
Louis and it's not value-neutral
this map was created by a whole slew of
cartographers and designers and
programmers etc who all came in with
their own personal and professional
worldviews and it's also created by
Google and Google has its own agendas
about what it wants to show me so to
quote that critical cartographer je be
highly maps are never value free images
except in the narrowest euclidean sense
they're not in themselves either true or
false
so maps are not neutral they have
stories to tell and they have agendas
and in his essay Harley goes on to say
that he views maps as a kind of language
and even if you don't leave this talk
like really excited about making
procedurally generated maps I hope that
you at least leave excited about reading
the maps in your life more critically as
kind of literature that has authors and
agendas so back to Google Maps here's
where I live this is San Francisco
can see what Google is prioritizing like
we've got all the streets here so I can
navigate when we've got all these points
of interest and that may be relevant to
me and like really to me I'm logged in
when I took this screenshot so we've got
my oral surgeon where I got my wisdom
teeth out we've got my office my
friend's office my favorite dumpling
place which are all points you wouldn't
see as just a casual user unless you
look for them but there's also a lot
that this map isn't showing me this is
certainly not all of San Francisco or
all that's relevant to me for example
here's a map of coyote sightings during
the day and during the night in San
Francisco and Google certainly not
showing me this by default and it might
be interesting too because I actually
encounter coyotes pretty often weirdly
it's also not showing me the indigenous
people who inhabited this land before
was colonized in Hort you know still
around to some degree like what were
their names and what were their
languages and where do they live this is
from Rebecca Solnit Atlas of San
Francisco Infinite City which is
fantastic I mean it's not showing me
Superfund sites all of these pink dots
are places where there is serious
industrial pollution that are still
being cleaned up pink is in progress
Fred is not started there's one green
dot for already cleaned up if you'll see
that cluster of pink dots at the bottom
there that's where I grew up so that's
cool sure that's fine
this is a really interesting historical
map in 1854 there is a serious cholera
epidemic in Soho neighborhood of London
and the physician John snow was trying
to figure out what the source was what
was causing it so he could stop it and
so what he did is he took a map of the
area and he went around and he put one
of these black rectangles you can see
here on every spot where he found a
death from cholera and it's a little
hard to see cuz it's all black and black
but there's a lot of black rectangles
right in the center of the map and
that's where the Broad Street fountain
is and so using this as a way to like
visualize that data he determined that
the Broad Street fountain was the
contaminated water source that was
causing this epidemic and was able to
stop it
this is a similar map it's using little
icons to show you where incidents occur
it tells you something pretty
interesting about where you might find
Bigfoot so that's these previous maps
have mostly been using symbols and
points on a map but we can also
communicate a lot using color and shade
here's a topographical map of San
Francisco which is pretty on trisomy
because I write it fixed-gear bicycle
and this map so this map is telling me
something really specific but it's in
and of itself a pretty politically
neutral message it's just saying here's
what's kind here's what's low and but
maps can be very politically minded and
have a very clear agenda this is another
map from Infinite City and Rebecca
Solnit in this map is trying to make an
argument that the Bay Area is a military
conservative brain trust and so she
selects all these locations that are
like military sites or corporations with
military contracts or conservative
think-tanks and points out their
connection to conservativism and so
she's making an argument with this
visualization that maybe the Bary isn't
so liberal but you can use selections or
selection is interesting in a map even
when it's leslie clearly saying
something really really opinionated this
is a map this is the first known map of
the city it's extremely agents from 1400
BCE and it's of the Babylonians sitting
napur and what's really cool about this
map is that it's all labeled in
cuneiform and we can translate it so we
actually know what they're pointing out
and we've got a canal here we've got a
ziggurat or a big orchard beautiful
gardens the nanak ate in the gate of the
unclean women and so by looking at what
this what is in this city and also what
the cartographer who made this map chose
to highlight we can get a little bit of
a sense of what it was like to be in
this place like we can understand like
the fortifications and what it was like
to get in and out of
city what the irrigation was like we
have a sense of these green spaces that
have been created and maybe even like a
hint about something about gender
happening it's definitely not you know a
complete story and there's a lot more to
be said about life in ancient Babylon
but this map tells us a lot and it's
really exciting to me good we can
translate it maps can also lie this is
this was created by a company that was
concerned about their intellectual
property so they put this city which is
highlighted in green aguilar town I
guess
agloe New York on the map and they just
put it there even though it's not real
so that if somebody else made a map of
the Catskills and it had a glow in New
York they would know that they had
stolen their data rather than doing
original research this is called a trap
town you often also see trap streets
where maybe somebody adds a little alley
in the corner that you know isn't gonna
like confuse anyone too much but they'll
know if somebody copies it because it's
not a real alley what's really
interesting about a glow I think is that
some years later somebody built a
general store in that area and they
named it a glow general store because
says it's a glow and since then the
store is closed it's been removed from
the map but I'd like to think that for
that period of time a glow was brought
into existence by this map and by this
cartographer here's another map that's
not telling us something pretty
important and it looks like a pretty
innocuous topographical map of a place
in Russia but if we go and look at the
satellite image we notice that there's
something pretty interesting up there
that they don't show on the map and this
is a the Krasnodar an R Sdn 20
transmitter and it was censored from
these maps to keep the location secret
so of course I want to talk about maps
of places that aren't real this one is
look very close to my hearts maybe the
first fictional map that I consumed
maybe that's true for you as well it's a
map of middle-earth from Lord of the
Rings and this map has
the locations that are important to the
book on it and we could track the
journey of the hobbits and so it tells
us a lot about the story and it also has
a form factor that tells us about the
world like it looks like it's written on
parchment with a quill pen and you know
if you imagine this map with the same
information on it but presented like
Google Maps and you didn't know anything
else about Lord of the Rings you would
have a really different sense of what
that story was like and what that world
felt like this is another fictional map
that I really love it's from the fifth
season by NK jemisin the map was created
by Tim Paul yeah it's an awesome book I
really recommend it and what's
interesting is that in terms of
information hierarchy the biggest thing
after the title of the map is these
tectonic plates now Stephanie not
something that Tolkien's showed on his
map but plate tectonics and earthquakes
are really really important to this
story and just by looking at this map
able to see that there's something going
on there where this is a point of
interest so in terms of creating
procedurally generated or just fictional
maps in general I want to think about
the different viewpoints that go into it
and there's you know the creator's
viewpoint so there's all my
preconceptions and the research I've
done my idea of what a city looks like
what a map should look like how streets
are laid out and then there's also the
fictional map maker the kind of the
narrator within my story like who is
this person and what is their
relationship to the territory that
they're mapping do they live there are
they a foreigner how do they feel about
the people who are there are they you
know a colonial force and then there are
the people who live in the map what are
their agendas how do they want to be
presented and viewed and what how do
they build their city how what kind of
structures do they make how do they plan
their roads what languages do they speak
and then of course there's the actual
viewer who's going to look at it who
maybe doesn't speak the fictional
language and what information do they
want to try to understand this fictional
place so my project I decide to make
tourist maps and I wanted to have a
sense that it's made by kind of a big
corporation
it isn't you know it's not like one of
those adventure travel places it's very
like stay in a nice hotel and
everything's gonna be great and shiny
and you're gonna have fun and be
beautiful and but I also wanted there to
be a little bit of an undertone like a
side note that maybe everything's not
quite as shiny as it's making it out to
be and I'll let you decide how well I've
accomplished that but and I like to
think of the map as a model and the
process of making map is the process of
modeling and models are inherently
incomplete and this is really really
good because it means you can ever
finish and and if they if we could make
a model that perfectly represented what
we were modeling it would raise all our
really disturbing philosophical ethical
questions also in terms of pocket
universes and so you have to think about
the constraints that you're gonna use in
your model and I always think of this
quote by my friend arias cuz I mean who
said all this stuff I make I make a
stupid as possible and I really try to
live by that I don't always but I really
strive for that and so I'm gonna talk
about the algorithms I used but keep in
mind that they're not always the most
modern algorithms than always the
fanciest and then always the most
accurate how to you know how the world
really works but they were the easiest
to use that got what in the simplest and
they got me the results that I wanted
and I think that's a good approach to
picking algorithms yeah but I encourage
you to look into this fancier ones
because they're all so neat so I
approached my mapping three kind of main
layers there's elevation and topography
and then population and then roads in
reality there's a lot more data but
those are the three main ones and I'll
go through these so we'll start with
terrain
I used simplex noise generate terrain
and simplex noise is like the
new-and-improved Perlin noise and not to
hate on Perlin noise that algorithm won
an Oscar which is more than most
algorithms can say
and so simplex noises a little nicer
it's a little less computationally
complex and it looks a little better it
has for your directional artifacts and
and what this is is I'm not going to
explain how it works involves lots of
matrices and complex stuff that is
interesting but I'm not going into it
because there's lots of libraries that
do this but it's pseudo-random gradient
noise so it creates really smooth
transitions between areas of light and
dark or high and low values so on this
visualization black is zero and white is
one and there's values between there but
it doesn't look this does not really
look like a map to me yet even though it
does have a compass rose and a little
scale
I had a cartography professor in college
who would know it was like the golden
rules you never ever allowed to turn in
a map that didn't have a scale and a
compass rose and I guess that really
stuck with me and so let's just put
nicer colors on it I stole these codes
directly from that topic girl grab
topographical map I showed you earlier
I'm because I thought it was pretty and
then I also so I've just bucket eyes the
values to these colors and then I'm also
gonna put little like grey lines when it
changes over from one bucket to the
other to make it kind of look like a
topographic map so we go from this to
this and already it looks a little more
like a map that's a little more exciting
what's cool about simplex and Perlin
noise is that it's really easy to tweak
it so one thing you can do is you can
change the amplitude and I did this
using an exponent to keep the value
between 0 and 1 and so when you raise a
value that's below 1 to 2 exponent
that's greater than 1 that it'll
increase so this is sort of inverse
amplitude that relationship but
basically if we raise end we can go from
this map which has all these different
scales on it to this map which is a lot
lower and maybe that's nice for a city
because we don't always build cities on
the hill use place in the world
tell that to San Francisco we can also
adjust the frequency of a map and this
sort of like zooms in and out of the map
and you do this by just multiplying the
X&Y coordinates that you're using to
calculate the noise by a certain
constant so I'll show you in one
dimension we have this line which we can
imagine was created by the noise
algorithm not just in Inkscape and then
if we change the frequency the red is
what our original curve just a little
smaller and now there's more data and
it's a little more up and down so in two
dimensions we go from this map to this
map and you can see there's the same
features but there's a little more going
on and then I think this is the coolest
thing you can tweak this is octaves of
noise and this adds roughness to the to
the gradient because if you use so flex
noise kind of like right out of the box
it's very very smooth and that doesn't
feel like how organic forms are like
they've you know been subjected to
construction and to erosion and there's
just a coarseness that we want to
emulate so to add octaves if we just
keep adding noise smaller noise on to
the noise we already made so it becomes
fractal noise and you just keep
decreasing it and so again I have our
one dimensional example and we can just
imagine that now it's a little bump here
so for our two-dimensional you go from
here maybe to here and the value there
like two four eight that we multiply our
frequency by is called the persistence
and that just affects how much impact
the over that octave has on the overall
result
so I'm pretty happy with this map with
this map actually I this one actually
already has a couple octaves applied to
it and so one loop so I'm gonna use this
to go forward and that's like I said not
a very interesting map so let's add an
ocean and I did this using midpoint
displacement so all I do is I pick a
start and an end point say this is where
the coastline starts this is where it
ends draw a line between it which
currently not super realistic coastline
well you know so I draw a perpendicular
line to it it's a certain length and you
can see it skewed down there's less
above the line and a little more below
and that's because I want it I want
would rather have the coastline move
towards the edge of the map so there's
more land visible to the viewer and then
I just look on this segment and find the
point of lowest elevation because that
seems sensible we want maybe want the
coastline to follow the lows in the map
and then just move the line divided into
two segments that touch at that point
and then we do this recursively so our
two new segments we make a little
smaller line and move the line to there
and just keep doing this and keep doing
it until we have this nice kind of
organic feeling coastline so everything
that's in this kind of funky shaped
quasi triangle that should be ocean now
and so we want instead of you know the
regular Hills we want this tall just
like slope down into the seabed and I'm
gonna set the water level the the sea
level to zero and everything below zero
will be underwater so this is pretty
simple
I just calculate the distance from any
point that's within our new ocean area
from the coastline and then I decrease
the elevation of that point
proportionally to the distance so I did
distance spread over ten thousand and I
just fiddled around with different
numbers until I got values that I
thought with nice
that's true of a lot of things on this
actually and so when we apply that we
get areas that are now underwater which
is great and you can see that the
coastline is kind of the wrong word for
this because it's not actually where the
coast is it's where we start going down
into the water and because we're going
down really slowly at first it's still
gonna be values greater than zero so
they're still gonna be above water so we
have this kind of like sloping Beach
which is nice and then here it is
already looks a little more like a real
habit excuse me so I'm excited about
water features now I'm just gonna keep
adding water features solicited rivers
I've tried doing midpoint displacement
for rivers and it made really boring
rivers because midpoint displacement
never kind of curves back on itself just
by nature of the way the algorithm works
and so instead I just put a point it got
a point in the direction and then I look
ahead from that point I put a few points
already just so that it's on the map but
this is how they were all created so I
look at the angle of the two previous
points and then I make an arc of two PI
over 3 radians and just those are my
options and so I pick the point of
lowest elevation because I want the
river to follow you know the low points
on the map so I've picked this point and
then I just keep doing this and you can
see it's following this valley which is
nice but it's also kind of going uphill
because this is not actually realistic
terrain and I wanted it to do this
because otherwise it would never get
anywhere would just make a little lake
and so it's following the lowest point
available to it not the lowest points
overall and we just keep going until we
hit the ocean and then I actually I
don't show this but I use midpoint
displacement between these points to
make even more granular shape so it
wouldn't be too jerky and then I did the
same thing I did the ocean I just kind
of in Reverse I just calculated the
distance from the center of the river
and make it lower in the center and less
elevation change so it's closer to its
original elevation further away and now
I have a river
Oh
so as an aside I tend to write code that
has bugs in it um I don't know maybe you
did too
um but what I learned in the process of
doing this this is one of my first
sojourners into doing visual generative
stuff is that visual bugs are awesome so
I'll leave it to you to consider like
the social and ecological conditions
that led to this map forming that was
fun so now many people people should
live in this place because I'm trying to
make a city and to do this I used two
different scales I used this just higher
in the center this is just an absolute
value function so it you know the dark
blue means a higher number closer to one
white is zero because I want people to
tend to live towards the center of the
city and then I did another round of
simplex noise just really simply simple
no octaves so because I don't want
everyone to actually live directly in
the center of the city I want there to
be neighborhoods and distributions and
an organic feel so I multiply those two
together and I get this map that has
tends to have people living towards the
center but they're still in clusters
basically they form neighborhoods which
is really great and now I wanted to find
what those neighborhoods are so I got
the local Maxima of this map and then I
did a Voronoi diagram and this a Voronoi
diagram divides a plane into regions or
Voronoi cells or neighborhoods based on
the difference between sites or in this
case local Maxima that are on the plane
and there are a lot of really cool ways
to calculate the position of Voronoi
cells and they're really efficient ways
really like it's clever ways but the
like really down dirty simple easy to
understand way to figure out where
Voronoi cells are is you just say for
any point any coordinate
it belongs to the Voronoi cell of the
closest site so you can just look at all
the sites figure out which ones closest
you got it that's your neighborhood or
that's your cell so that's what I did
and now I've got these neighborhoods and
they're actually site they're local
Maxima that are off screen because this
Maps a little wider than the
presentation which is why there are
cells on the sides that don't look like
they have sites on this map and so for
my next tip I wanted to add a little bit
of parks and beaches also to give you
know a little bit of livability to my
cities I did this a little bit of a
slapdash way it's something I want to
refactor but it worked well enough and I
just said if if the population density
is below a certain threshold which I can
adjust or it's above or the the
elevation is above a certain threshold
that means it's a park and I can change
those thresholds so that there's more
Park area or less park area depending on
you know what I want from the city and
then I also said you know our coastline
is not really at the water so everything
between the coastline and the water
let's call that the beach so now we have
something that looks kind of like a map
also kind of looks like a Rorschach test
it's missing something really important
which is like human structures and roads
and I tried a lot of different things in
making roads and there are a lot of
academic papers out there from the games
industry and so forth about how to
generate roads I read a bunch of them
and I found them all really confusing
and all that useful and sorry if any of
you are listening I'm sure they're great
for other people but they weren't useful
to me so after a number of false starts
some of which were more ominous than
others
I settled on this system and so you
started the city center and I create a
really small like one pixel line segment
that has a direction just to kind of
seed my map and then I propose
continuing that segment forward at the
same in the same direction for another
unit of a given segment length and which
is adjustable and then and then I look
around within a given arc kind of like I
did with a river to try to find the
point
that'll be most level because I want my
Road if possible to be as flat as it can
be and so this is the perturbation value
it's a pretty small arc but it's
adjustable but much smaller than for the
river and then now we have a proposed
point here and we have to evaluate if
it's acceptable so it has to be on the
map it has to not be underwater and and
if it's in a park I reject it 40% of the
time just so that there are fewer roads
through parks but not no roads to parks
and then the segment length has to be
greater than the minimum segment like
this set just so the recursion stops
eventually so this segment like this
little segment proposal passes so we're
gonna keep this one and then we're gonna
fork off from either side of our
original segment I'm pretty similar
except the only the difference is that
the segment length and is changed by
between fifty two hundred ten percent
and that keeps it a little variable but
by and large the segment Leafs are
getting smaller as they fork off from
the parent and I use a smaller
perturbation value half as much just so
they weren't really really acute or
obtuse angles so here's our two forks
they've been accepted they're all
they're both good and then we do this
recursively we treat these new endpoints
we've added as you know as our origins
and we fork off and continue from them
but something interesting happened here
these two lines connected and this is
really important so when the segment is
proposed it checks if the end point is
within a given radius of some already
existing accepted end point curtains
start point and if it is it moves the
point that we proposed on top of the
existing segment so as a little bigger
example let's say this is the dotted one
is our proposed segment and the solid
line is our existing segment it checks
they're in the same radius so it just
moves our proposed segment to connect to
the existing one and this is really
really important because without this
you just ended up with this labyrinth of
dead ends and no streets ever connect to
each other and it's not terribly
traversable as a road network that's
great and then we just get to keep doing
this keep doing it and another nice
thing happened we made a bridge so why
do point hits water it doesn't reject it
outright
it goes to an edge case and it says it
tries to decide if it wants to try to
make a bridge and this is correlated to
the population density so that there
tends to be bridges built where people
live and so if it accepts that it'll try
to just make the coin a little longer to
get to land and then the segment
direction is shifted so that it's
perpendicular to the river just to make
it look a little more realistic so now
we have bridges which are very useful
and we just keep iterating on this until
we have all bunch of rows and this is
also really adjustable I've changed the
perturbation level for this map to be
really really low and now I have a map
that's much more of a grid it feels
maybe more like a modern pre-planned
City or I can make the perturbation
really really high and it's even more
curvy and weird and maybe feels like a
more City that was built more
organically maybe it's a little older
and then we can also adjust the segment
length just to change the road density
this is the longer minimum segment
length
just gives you a different feel in the
city but I'm pretty happy with this map
so the next step is just to add some
actual points of interest to it so I
generated a language and that's one step
and label so I might use my language to
name all the neighborhoods and to name
the city and put some restaurants we've
got a tea house and some interesting
sites onto my map and then I put it into
the context of a kind of whole tourist
guide or maybe like tourist pamphlet
guidebook it's a little long and so
we've got you know our beautiful
photograph of our city and the weather
right now some information about the
region I really proud of the seven-day
forecast it's like no question my
favorite part of this project is that
you get a weather forecast and now we
have this beautiful interactive map and
we've got this tea house that everyone
loves this restaurant that not so much
loved and we have this temple here
devoted to the that God is where who is
a winding river with a tough to grasses
head and the locals like to leave
sacrifices of teeth behind and all like
you ponder whose teeth those are and
where they come from and just some more
information about our city something
about the language in the wildlife yeah
and so that's that's what I did with
these maps
[Applause]
okay I got one question thank you
and that is what software programs today
used to create these maps well I wrote
all in JavaScript which I regret and I
but here we are too much work to go back
now and then I rendered all in p5.js
which is a really cool library p5 is
awesome thank you it was really good for
making these like skyline images
it wasn't an amazing fit for the maps
because I didn't really use any of the
features and make it cool like that it's
like browser native this is actually
just like static image of the map and
whereas this is a rendered p5 like I
rendered in p5 and then exported the
canvas and so I could have really done
that in any like graphics library but p5
was really cool and it's what I used
it's very easy to use and I recommend it
yeah and I think the only other library
used was a simplex noise generator I
used heated random a lot if you did
random is great and yes
basically
no but it sounds fantastic oh yeah look
it up I'm sorry
yeah so I have not heard of the book
algorithmic beauty of cities but it
sounds awesome
yes so the question was what books did
inspire me um gosh that's it I've been
thinking about maths for so long I
haven't thought that consciously about
it um I took an archaeology class in
which we read the city in the city by
China Mieville yeah and I the story
itself didn't stick with me that much
but the concept there's kind of there's
two cities they like are co-located but
mutually exclusive it's weird and very
interesting that really stuck with me
and definitely Rebecca Solnit outlets
infinite city was a really cool like
look through just different ways of
presenting the same space and with
different agendas and different
perspectives there's the the essay by JB
Harley and that I mentioned maps
it's like Maps power and something it's
wonderful it's from a bear collection
about landscapes that's pretty
interesting
but his essay is really fantastic it
really breaks down the ways in which
maps can be used for propaganda and to
reinforce like existing power structures
it's really worth reading it's pretty
short yeah yeah it's all on my github
and the map repo is called maps very
creatively and all of the code for this
city generator is also there the
language generators there sorry it's
kind of messy but
yeah I considered that when I was
thinking about when I was approaching
this project I ended up not doing it
because I was excited about generating
my own terrain and but I think it's a
really cool idea I think would be a
little bit of a different project which
would also be really cool so I do think
that's a good sorry the question was did
I consider using existing city maps and
modifying them and the answer is I
considered it and I think it'd be
awesome but for a really different
project oh well go for it
yes I have a little tool that generates
procedurally generates languages
yeah that's one of the things I have I
think in a branch on my laptop and I've
used the the neighborhood like certain
neighborhoods can have different
perturbation levels so that maybe like
one feels like it was planned a little
differently than another so yes yes in
the back for a what have I considered
running simulations of this for a city
planet no I really like I said earlier
about models and constraints I really
limited myself to the scope of a city
and I don't think it scales very well so
if I try to make this into multiple
cities it would look pretty funky and if
I made it into entire world well I guess
I mean the real limitation is that my
code is pretty inefficient and it
wouldn't would take too long to run the
planet scale and but it's really
intended to be used at this size yes I
don't know I think there are more
realistic algorithms and I know the
diamond square algorithm I don't know if
that's more realistic but it's another
approach or using Voronoi cells and
changing the elevation that way our
different perches but I'm not aware of
any studies specifically though they
might exist about how realistic simplex
no he's actually is yes
and so the question is did I consider
stimulating traffic to see to test my
roads and the answer is sort of no sort
of yes I looked at a lot of different
approaches in general to mapping and
some of them are really simulation based
and they're really really cool like
there are ways of mapping terrain where
you just basically let let erosion take
place over the Train you've generated to
make it more realistic and it's awesome
or like actually having traffic models
to create your streets and I decided
that was too much work for what I was
trying to accomplish but yeah yes yeah
so that happens there's a set like
starting segment length of a certain
number of pixels and then as it Forks it
gets a little smaller or mostly smaller
and then also as the roads snap together
the length will change so there's just a
little bit like chaos introduced to the
road length both by like calling random
and also by connecting roads together
yes
I would love to do the perspective of
like a kid who lives in this city and
have like kind of like a hand-drawn map
that shows maybe the spots that are
important to that kid which are really
would seem really like uninteresting or
trivial to somebody else like you know
this is my favorite Boulder I think that
would be really interesting perspective
to show I'd like to make that hmm and it
would be interesting to look maybe from
I'd like to look kind of politically at
like the conflict maybe between like an
official map versus an indigenous map
and what that would look like in a space
yes
yeah so the question was have I
considered modeling it by changing
population over time the answer again is
that like all other simulations I
decided it was too much work but I think
it's really cool and people have done
really interesting work doing maps over
time that I've definitely read papers
where people have done that where they
produce really interesting results I
think it's worth doing yes
yeah so the question is how do I like
curate
which cities I decide to keep after one
is generated and the answer is I
actually pretty much keep all of them
it's like pretty a like thing this
generator is pretty reliable and all in
advance I'll set the presets how I want
so i generate the data about the city
first and so I'll know like should this
city have an ocean should it have a
river and then I'll turn on and off
those features and I'll you know I can
set the perturbation or randomize and it
usually like it's it's pretty consistent
unusually happy on the first pass with
what I've got all right I think that's
my time thank you so much
[Applause]